>>> IF I'M BEING HONEST, LEEK
IT'S REALLY HARD FOR ME TO
CONNECT WITH GUYS.
CAUSE I KIND OF HAVE A BIG
PERSONALITY.
I'VE TRIED INTERNET DATING.
AND YOU KNOW, GETTING HOOKED UP
BY MY FRIENDS.
NOBODY NEVER REALLY WANTS TO
ACTUALLY DATE ME, YOU KNOW.
IT HURTS.
I WANT TO BE IN LOVE JUST LIKE
ANY OTHER GIRL.
>> THIS ENTIRE DINNER WAS LAID
OUT WITH FLOWERS, AND I WAS
LIKE, WHAT IS THIS FOR?
AND HE WAS LIKE, JUST FOR YOU
BEING YOU.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> I WAS NEVER THE TYPE OF GIRL
THAT REALLY DATED A LOT.
YOU KNOW I GOT MY FIRST
BOYFRIEND AT 18.
WE WERE ON AND OFF FOR LIKE 17
YEARS AND I HAVEN'T FELL IN LOVE
WITH ANYBODY SINCE.
AND THIS JOB, IT DOES NOT MAKE
IT EASY TO MEET MEN BECAUSE I'M
ALWAYS WORKING.
IT FEELS LIKE THE ONLY MEN THAT
I INTERACT WITH IS THE ONES THAT
I WORK WITH, YOU KNOW?
SOMETIMES IT'S NOT A BAD THING.
>> I JUST DON'T WANT TO BE ON
CAMERA.
OKAY?
>> WAIT, YOU'RE NOT ASHAMED TO
BE WITH ME, ARE YOU?
>> OF COURSE NOT, LESLIE.
IT'S JUST, I MEAN, WE'RE AT WORK
RIGHT NOW.
>> COME ON BABY, TRUST ME.
>> MM, MM!
I GUESS YOU COULD SAY LESLIE AND
I HAVE BEEN GETTING -- CLOSER
THIS YEAR.
>> I LIKE KYLE.
HE'S GOT THIS NERDY, GOOFY,
CARTOONISH-TYPE FACE.
AND HE MAKES ME FEEL REALLY
SPECIAL, SO.
YOU KNOW, I WAS THINKING LIKE
MAYBE TONIGHT WE CAN TAKE TO IT
THE NEXT LEVEL?
>> YOU KNOW, I'VE NEVER GONE ALL
THE WAY.
>> YOU KNOW I'M GONNA TAKE CARE
OF YOU.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> KYLE AND I KIND OF HAVE SOME
DIFFERENT LIFE EXPERIENCES.
KYLE'S NEVER HAD SEX BEFORE.
>> I DON'T NORMALLY GET INVOLVED
WITH CAST RELATIONSHIPS.
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
KYLE TO LOSE HIS VIRGINITY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> SO ARE YOU AND LESLIE
GONNA -- YOU KNOW.
>> OH YEAH I HEARD ABOUT THAT --
>> WHAT?
>> YEAH, SORRY, I TOLD HIM.
>> I DON'T KNOW, OKAY?
>> SORRY I JUST DIDN'T THINK WAS
>> IT WASN'T A BIG DEAL --
>> I'VE BEEN WAITING FOR THIS MY
WHOLE LIFE.
I GUESS THE ONLY THING I REALLY
STRUGGLE WITH IS -- THE COLIN
STUFF.
>> YOU SEXY VANILLA MUFFIN.
I JUST WANT TO PLOW YOUR ASS!
I WANT TO HAVE SEXUALS WITH YOU,
MR. COLIN JOST!
>> WHY DOES EVERYONE THINK
THAT'S REAL?
SHE'S JUST DOING A CHARACTER.
IT'S LIKE ENTERTAINMENT.
OKAY?
I'M NOT DOING THIS, I ACTUALLY
DON'T WANT TO DO THIS ANYMORE.
>> KYLE HAS NOTHING TO WORRY
ABOUT.
ME AND COLIN ARE STRICTLY
PROFESSIONAL.
PEOPLE MAKE A BIG DEAL OUT OF IT
BUT IT'S TRULY JUST FOR THE
SHOW.
>> THAT LITTLE BITCH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
NOTHING.
>> DON'T BE LIKE THAT.
>> IT'S JUST THE WHOLE WORLD
THINKS YOU GUYS ARE TOGETHER.
>> BUT YOU KNOW THAT I DON'T
LIKE HIM LIKE THAT.
IT'S JUST FOR TV.
AND YOU KNOW WHEN THE TVs COME
OFF -- SO DOES THIS.
>> TELL ME I'M NOT DREAMING.
>> YOU ARE NOT.
>> BABY!
WOW.
THAT WAS -- AMAZING.
>> YES.
AND I GUESS IT'S SAFE TO SAY
THAT --
>> EXCUSE ME MISS --
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
GOD DAMN.
DID Y'ALL [ BLEEP ] IN MY
DRESSING ROOM?
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]